time for our thursday in season draft
the most important match-ups of the
upcoming slate of games and christopher
i've got the
trivia question for you to determine who
gets the first pick the washington
nationals won the world series last
night as a wild card team who was the
last team to win the super bowl as a
wild card oh the last team to win the
super bowl as a wild card okay hold on
that's the question yep just give me a
second oh man i i want to i want to say
the i want to say the new york giants i
just want to make sure but the ravens
were they a wild card team the next year
uh
i believe they were the ravens the
baltimore ravens 2012 raisins
it's in 2010.
not a team that played in the wild card
round because division winners play in
the wild card round half of them do wild
card team five seasons yeah that's
that's fine print that's like so that's
not fine
they played in the wild card game
they're in the wild card okay
yes i knew yeah the the packers in 2010
were the six seed yes oh now you know
okay well i did i thought of them
originally you know but yeah
you know i was thinking of first and
second round or no team with the first
round bye is what i was thinking
well that wasn't the question if that
would have been the question then your
answer would have been really clarified
i'm throwing the challenge flag go ahead
pick your stupid match okay and i'll
beat you go
sunday night football ravens and the
patriots and we've we've heard
and seen what the patriots do to
quarterbacks who are in their first
couple of years in the nfl
but we really haven't seen a quarterback
like lamar jackson take over the way
that he has for the baltimore ravens the
best quarterback of the 2018 class right
now and i don't think there's a a close
number two
uh and we see lamar jackson against the
patriots defense to me that's that
matchup is going to determine whether or
not the ravens can beat the new england
patriots can lamar jackson move the ball
with his legs with his arms against that
crippling and stifling patriots defense
for me that's the the most important by
far matchup of the weekend yeah it's
certainly a big one there's a few
matchups in this game that are
interesting and i might save one for
myself later on but yes i mean that's
that's the cream of the crop just uh
belichick's plan of attack vs lamar
jackson and this offense that's
different for the nfl and attacks you
differently than most teams so i'm
certainly intrigued i can't wait for
sunday night football this week i mean
this is an awesome football game uh
teams that are big and physical and
creative on both sides of the ball and
that's why it's going to be a can't miss
one of the can't miss games of the
weekend all right you know one of the
big other big games of the weekend that
feel like isn't getting as much
attention because the quarterbacks hurt
but hey the kansas city chiefs hosting
the minnesota vikings i mean hey the
chiefs are they're gonna be fi if they
lose this game this week they're five
and four i mean that's troublesville i
mean hey i understand that the afc west
is not exactly a juggernaut and it feels
good but man they just you know the
chiefs you don't want to be playing in
the wild card round they'd certainly
like to have a bye week as a first or
second you know seed in the afc uh and
they just seem to keep leaving the door
open for teams like the raiders to hang
around and maybe you know still win the
afc west barring something happen i
don't think that i don't expect that to
happen but the matchup i really look at
is is zimmer versus andy reed i mean
andy reid he was pretty creative last
week you know it goes back into my
little pet peeve of like i want to go
where are some of more of these plays
when patrick mahomes plays you know i i
like some of the things they did on that
side of the ball they're going to
continue to have to be creative and andy
reid's going to have to find ways
because yes matt moore is not patrick
mahomes we know that and mike zimmer is
a defensive coach that you know the the
game plan doesn't vary a whole lot
always he kind of this is what we do and
i'm really good at coaching it we know
what beats us and we know our flaws to
our scheme so we're really good at like
kind of not letting that happen to us uh
but andy reid you know i think he's
going to have to have a good day as far
as a good week of game planning uh to
help matt moore running the ball and
find ways to get the ball to tyreek hill
and sammy watkins so they can make some
plays on that viking secondary
yeah i i agree with everything you said
but i don't think that's the most
important match-up of the game and you
got the right game but you got the wrong
match up and i'm going to stick with
that game but i'm going to flip it
around okay her cousins against that
chief's defense and kirk cousins whose
opportunities for being salty are
quickly diminishing by the way kirk
cousins just named the nfc's offensive
player of the month for october
he's going to have to continue that pace
that we saw if the vikings want to win
critical matchups in kansas city and
next week in dallas and with the chiefs
this idea of the blitz chris we've
talked about this before kirk cousins is
fine until the pocket collapses once the
pocket collapses he can't run away from
pressure he can't buy time by sliding
around and jumping around like tom brady
does when it collapses he's done so he's
gonna have to make quick decisions find
the open receiver find the hot route get
the ball to the guy when he sees those
blitzes coming and the one thing about
the chiefs and you've advocated for them
to do this blitz and blitz and blitz
some more force the issue so that you
get the opposing offense off the field
whether it's through a turnover a punt
or a touchdown get them off the field so
that we can get our offense back on the
field and i think the ability of kirk
cousins to handle the blitzes from the
chief's defense and specifically is
dialed up by steve spagnolo that's going
to be the key to this game more
important in my mind than the kansas
city offense against the vikings defense
yeah well of course i disagree i mean
both of these were in my mind as far as
which one to go with but i went with
mine because i like mine better uh but
either way you're right i mean that is
an important matchup i truly i had it
down here too because i was like kind of
going back and forth which one should i
pick here uh ultimately i thought well
wait a minute wait wait wait
you've been the guy who has been
just doing everything you can to
convince the chief i know aggressive on
defense i get it and now they're being
aggressive on defense and it presents a
specific problem for an immobile
quarterback and you don't make that your
match up yeah no i'm not necessarily as
worried about that as much as i you know
again kansas city's defense i like
everything they're doing definitely
minnesota's offense is rolling it's
tough to depend on but the big thing to
me ultimately is whether kansas city can
move the ball on a defense that's one of
the better defenses in football you know
the kansas city kansas city's defense
could play really good and hold them to
20 points or something like that but if
andy reid and company can't move the
ball on this vikings defense and he
can't find some tricks to get on mike
zimmer then it's not gonna matter that's
that's that's what ultimately why i went
with mine okay so you good now can i can
can i thank my pick all right you jerk
bucks wide receivers versus seahawks
secondary okay
the seahawks i think we both have talked
about this a lot uh a little concerned
about their past defense all right
that's that's an issue for me and we've
seen it a few weeks in a row now where
teams are they're moving the ball on the
seahawks defense and this is a dangerous
game a little bit for seattle i think
you know the bucks yeah they're losing
backs are against the wall they really
got nothing to lose come on none of us
are expecting them to really make a run
or anything like that but they're big up
front on the offensive line to where i
think they could slow down that front
from seattle a little bit and with
zimmer i mean uh with uh aryans and
leftwich's you know creative ability to
throw the ball down the field and jameis
winston's aggression you know that would
be one of those games where i'm not
picking it this way but would not be
shocked if we looked up in the fourth
quarter and we're watching games on
sunday if like tampa bay is losing by a
field goal or up by a field goal
something like that i do think they'll
be able to move the ball on the seattle
seahawks and i think jameis winston has
the capability with some of those
receivers and he's got a disposal that
they can make some plays against that
seahawks d
and i'm not going to make this my next
matchup but if i was going to go for one
from that game it was going to be pete
carroll versus bruce arians they've got
that history from their time together in
the nfc west some and bruce arians
called the seahawks the
stadium the cardinals home field because
they had had some success there and it
was aryan's last game with the cardinals
they were eight point underdogs the
cardinals went in there and i probably
should have gone without phrasing
because you're right that's really what
i'm getting down to i made it about the
players but you're right it's still that
i didn't want to do the coach thing
because i just did the coach thing but
man mike to what you're saying it too
like man the seahawks are the 27th pass
defense in football i mean we don't see
that very much i think that speaks to
some of the issues they got back there
and why they traded for a guy like
quandre diggs for in detroit last week
and hey the the buccaneers have lost
three in a row it's the first time in
bruce aaron's career as a head coach
he's lost three in a row and it could go
to four in a row and then next week he
plays his former team the cardinals
their first game back at home after that
seven week break due to playing in
london and bye weeks and whatnot all
right last match up for me guy we talked
about earlier in the program maybe
talking about him again coming up here
in a few minutes but baker mayfield
taking on the broncos defense at a time
when it feels like the team is kind of
under siege they were two and five this
is a must win for the cleveland browns
and it's not going to be an easy win the
broncos are tough to beat at home they
looked awful a couple of weeks ago
against the chiefs i'll give you that
but that the broncos better than their
record would suggest and the broncos are
not going to be an easy team for the
browns to beat i think they'll win but
it's going to be an important matchup
for baker mayfield who is facing a lot
of adversity on the field
facing some adversity off the field can
he get it together for this game lead
the offense and get the browns to three
and five going into a game against the
bills and then those two games against
the steelers in three weeks the
opportunity is still there for the
browns to become a potential playoff
team but if they lose to the broncos on
sunday i think it's done at two and six
they're gonna have a hard time digging
out of it and baker mayfield is gonna
have to have one of his best games of
the year if they want to get past the
broncos defense chris yeah i agreed i
mean it's not going to be easy i don't
care that joe flacco is not playing
quarterback it's not about that you know
like what you're saying anyways that
broncos d is still really good
and the browns find ways to screw things
up on a weekly basis on offense well at
least when you look at their losses you
know it's it's it's them with
self-inflicting wounds more times than
not um so that is a big matchup and of
course the microscopes on baker mayfield
because they're losing and because he's
on a million national commercials and
then you know he gets testy with a
reporter yesterday people are going to
be watching extra clothes so i hear you
there all right i'm going to go i don't
i was thinking about the ravens game
again but i want to spread the wealth as
far as match-ups are concerned and
i'm looking at more specifically the
philadelphia eagles offensive line
versus the chicago bears d-line and this
one all right this is where it's going
to be interesting to me you know the
chicago bears they're one of the best
defenses in football we know that
they're reeling the defense has not been
as dominant as last year you know last
year i don't think we would question
they were the best defense in the sport
you know this year
you know it's questionable whether you
think they're top five or not now some
of that is because of the offense but
you know i do think to a big part of
this game the eagles i think are
switching to we need to run the ball
more and impose our physical will on
teams and i think they'll again try to
do that uh to the chicago bears and
where i really think it's important is
you know with desean jackson looking
like he's gonna come back if the eagles
o line starts to have their way and open
up holes man that's going to make the
bear's defense have to be maybe a little
vulnerable to the pass game where carson
wentz can strike and do that and that's
where i go to that match up because the
bears have to win with their defense and
if they can't kind of win with their
defense and control the game that way i
don't think they're going to win the
game ultimately and that'll be one i'm
watching there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports